I'm Dr Nehemiah Mabry I'm a civil
structural engineer today I'll be
answering your questions from Twitter
this is City support
[Music]
at JB rice rice JB asks how do you
safely demolish a 28-story building so
the goal when you're demolishing the
building is to get it to implode or
basically collapse directly on its own
footprint the structural drawings are
studied load bearing supports are
identified and detonators are placed
there so that they can sequentially or
at a certain time all be executed and
then the remaining portion of the
building has nowhere to fall but
directly down and then the weight of the
building itself then causes it to
continue to collapse upon itself at
Aaron of Boston asks how are underwater
tunnels made I.E similar tunnel first
you have to make sure that you can get
down under the water to begin the work
what we do is Place makeshift dams down
into the water to seal out certain parts
of the water and then the water inside
of that dam is literally pumped out so
now you have a section of the water that
workers or Machinery can get down and we
have what we call a tunnel bore machine
that can then tunnel through in the
direction that we want the tunnel and
also keep the pressure or the water out
and that being done allows there to be
some sort of prefabricated
tunnel and by prefabricated I mean it
was created outside of the water to then
be placed into the boring hole sometimes
this is done on both sides of the tunnel
at the same time and then when it's done
the makeshift dam is removed the water
then continues and the tunnel at that
point is connected to the road that
leads to it at our key underscore
tradition asks what city has the best
Urban Design Amsterdam in the
Netherlands is known for its canals
which create a pretty nice grid I would
say in general Singapore has been
recognized as a country that has pretty
good Urban Design newer cities have the
advantage of looking at how cities were
designed in the past and identifying
areas that were perhaps not as optimal
you want to make sure that there's a
significant amount of Housing and then
there's more room to develop as
necessary you want to make sure that
there is affordable housing and then you
want to make sure that there's efficient
routes from where there are primary
residential neighborhoods to the areas
where people do a lot of their working
such that you don't have to have
everyone driving individually creating
more carbon emission you want to see
green spaces essentially Harmony between
the ways that people live they work and
they play at me Al Janae asks isn't it
crazy how someone designed roads and
highways to get places like how do they
know where to go in some respects we
have our indigenous ancestors to thank
particularly here in America oftentimes
these roles were footpaths people were
traveling from one place to another and
they were just basically trying to go in
the optimum directions to get from one
place to another to another natural
resource Rose over time kind of
naturally took the place of what were
just heavily trodden paths at Sydney Ray
497 ask honestly how the heck did
Engineers reverse the flow of the
Chicago River in 1900. naturally the
Chicago River had a flow north into Lake
Michigan as the city began to grow a lot
of pollution from the city would go into
Lake Michigan and they ran into a
problem of actually consuming their own
pollution when they got their water from
Lake Michigan what they basically did
was locate a high point not too far west
of Chicago and they dug a canal that
redirected the water and because it was
on the other side of the high point the
gravity naturally caused it to flow
Downstream as opposed to upstream and so
they basically just rerouted a section
of it at Engineers underscore feed asks
what is the most mind-blowing
engineering marble you know about one of
my favorite Bridges is the malao viaduct
it's actually the tallest bridge in the
world it's about a mile and a half long
and the height of the towers are
actually taller than the Eiffel Tower is
a cable Stay Bridge one of my favorites
cable State Bridges transfer the loads
or the strength that the cables
experience to support the deck of the
bridge and they transfer it back to each
individual Tower it really looks sleek
because it has to be symmetrical and the
fact that it's a tall bridge means that
you can get nice clouds and fog that
makes for some pretty stunning
photography at Mouse underscore B
question for New York City if you had to
do it all over again would you build
elevated trains instead of subways
they're basically pros and cons for
building underground versus above ground
wherever you're above ground you have
the convenience of being able to work on
it quite easily one of the disadvantages
is that you're more exposed to the
weather an advantage of having Subways
underground is they don't have to worry
about the constant snow load or the
winds that say a road would have to deal
with at this point I think it's probably
a better underground you really don't
want the additional congestion of having
to repair around all the people that are
already in New York City at Nico
entombed X how the frick are skyscrapers
even made this is a pretty basic
skyscraper design it gets narrower as
you get up higher but a lot of times
these structures are designed by either
reinforced concrete or very very large
steel i-beams this is a very small cut
out model of one where you have a web a
narrow web and then you have a wide
flange at top or bottom i-beams can form
horizontal supports or very thick ones
can be used as columns for a skyscraper
and the more you want your particular
eye beam to carry the thicker you will
make these different components at oh
barely underscore asks to be honest if
you aren't using number nine steel rebar
bars and concrete beams what kind of
civil engineer are you so what she is
referring to is the still bars that we
use inside of concrete to basically
reinforce the strength steel is very
strong in what we like to call tensile
strength it can resist being pulled
whereas concrete not so much strong in
that type of force is much stronger and
compressive
strength being pressed on so in certain
parts of our concrete we would Place
steel bars of different sizes to be able
to reinforce the strength in that area
of the structure and the number of the
rebar represents the diameter of that
particular steel bar now number nine it
represents one square inch of
cross-section so it makes the math a lot
easier to calculate every time we add
one number nine rebar we've just added
one square inch of Steel reinforcement
for that area at Leah leasing our rope
bridge is built so the first step is
just to see how can you get that first
rope from one side to the other it
probably was either walked over or hiked
over at first or perhaps thrown or shot
over using an arrow in some of the
earlier cases and once that first rope
reaches the other side now you have a
system to get other things across using
a system of pulleys and levers these
rope bridges are very basic cases of
suspension bridges at Bond underscore
Bond 222 how do Bridges not collapse but
we designed Bridges to be able to last
for 50 to 70 years on average so in the
case of a suspension bridge what you
have is a long wire cable connecting
from One support to the other they have
vertical cables that are going down from
that cable that are in tension or being
pulled down by the weight of that
particular bridge deck when this is
happening that is actually transferring
the load back to the top cable and then
the top cable is responsible for
transferring that load back to the tower
that then support then distributes the
load across these columns and transfer
it back to its foundation we run a lot
of tests on the type of material to make
sure that it can withstand all of the
temperature Cycles or the wet the dry
Cycles the fatigue from the constant use
of traffic we do this to a point that we
have a high reliability or high level of
confidence it's not going to collapse
for a significant amount of time after
inberry asks the civil engineers in this
city really have zero clue on traffic
flow how can 90 of likes be read as you
get to them traffic studies are based on
data they look at the number of cars
that are actually passing through a
particular intersection or heading in
One Direction at different times of the
day they measure this sometimes by using
sensors in the ground sometimes there
are cameras or they can be old-fashioned
and actually have a person go out there
and literally count the cars whenever
this changes they're able to optimize
the phases or the changing of the lights
at different times of the day they want
to prioritize where there is a heavier
flow of traffic roads that have a high
volume of traffic there's a higher speed
they're given more time for their red
and yeah even yellow lights because they
don't want to jam up traffic in that
direction so that being said perhaps
you're on a road that doesn't have high
priority or
there needs to be a refresh in the
traffic studies of that area at Toronto
Caillou did the London Bridge actually
fall down yes multiple times there was a
bridge around the 11th century that was
reportedly torn down by a viking
Invasion however after that was rebuilt
the nursery rhyme we were referring to
could likely be speaking of the fact
that during the longest tenured Bridge
of about 622 years the London Bridge
actually went through a lot of fire it
experienced a lot of wind or tornadoes
it experienced a lot of rain and so over
time it became a joke that not only the
London Bridge falling down but one poem
written about the same time States the
London Bridge is broken down speaking to
the constant need of repair that it was
in next question what do you think how
will our future cities look like a b or
city any highly Advanced city is going
to need to make sure that there is an
integration of green spaces not only for
oxygen but just for our enjoyment and
well-being the more that we get rid of
our natural green spaces the less we
were able to have that oxygen naturally
generated in our environment I see that
they're all high vertical structures
and that really speaks to the fact that
we're going to need to get more and more
comfortable with building up because
building out isn't going to always be an
option at asce tweets how will Florida
cities work what can civil engineers do
now to help us get there first of all
American Society of civil engineers I
would think that you would know the
answer already shout out to y'all you
can look at things such as artificial
Islands or oil rigs or even cruise ships
to get an idea of how these things could
be worked oftentimes they are built with
anchors connected to the ocean bed or
the sea floor to make sure it doesn't
float away other times they can have
very long Columns of significant weights
distributed underneath the platform so
that it's able to Be steady and then
weight can be billed or structures can
then be built on top of it at Babylon on
the replay asks I know it is a rain
frequently quiet but why the frick does
the drainage suck so bad in so many
areas like did the city Engineers not
consider rain at all I'm pretty sure
they consider rain but they consider a
certain amount of rainfall and that was
based on the historical data at the time
that they designed the city as the
environment begins to change and things
begin to switch up sometimes our amount
of rainfall that was once expected to be
very very rare becomes more frequent and
so oftentimes you do have puddling that
cause Engineers have to go back and
redesign we begin to now have new
information that allows us to design
more for the present than for the past
and so you could be experiencing
something that just is in need of a
revised design at Catherine gold asks
question for engineer types if you walk
under a bridge and you see crumbling
concrete an exposed rebar is that bad
asking for the city of Cleveland well
it's not necessarily bad to be honest
the concrete that is at the bottom is
actually used as cover to cover the
steel rebar we've only designed it so
that the steel is actually resisting
most of the strength the problem however
is that that steel is now exposed and so
as it still begins to corrode and rust
then it actually does get bad so if you
see exposed Steel in some cases it just
needs to be cleaned and recovered in
other cases it could be pretty bad at
Chrissy how are sinkholes created my
sister you cut a hole in the counter and
put a sink in it
sinkholes are basically just areas of
non-compacted soil sometimes there was
water there that has been drained out
and so now you have this big old Gap
underneath the surface that whenever
experiences enough weight at the top it
could sink at lit industrial asks how
would you design a new city in the
desert with an unlimited budget this
brings to mind a city that's already
been proposed to Saudi Arabia known as
the line as his nickname neon pretty
much very narrow City that stretches
several miles there will literally be
two walls that are able to support
several overhangs or cantilevers as we
call it that can support green spaces
residential housing Transportation when
you're just looking at a short footprint
and you're building up as opposed to out
you can increase the optimum travel from
one end to the other by making public
transportation just a straight line
being in the desert when you're thinking
structurally sand is actually pretty
strong it has a high bearing capacity
that being said you you have to bring in
additional cement and other materials to
make sure that this sand can consolidate
and not be as Shifty as we know sand to
be I think it's pretty challenging but
I'm not one to rule out what human
Ingenuity can do at Alexis underscore
Britney asks what does building a bridge
even have to do with math how we design
a bridge we have to start by saying
whenever a force is applied over an area
we divide the area that's going to
experience that Force by the value of
that Force to get what we call the
stress so there's math right there we
measure the strength of the concrete in
terms of pounds per square inch how many
pounds per square inch of area can this
take perpendicularly we call it
compression strength the cylinders are
taken into the lab and put into a very
high strength compression testing device
Until It Breaks until it fails and then
we can say to ourselves this concrete
has a failure strength of 5 000 pounds
per square inch we then come back to our
structure our bridge and we determine if
that concrete is strong enough to hold
up the weight that we're expecting this
bridge to experience in other words it's
a lot of math
Ross mingna asks how is everybody fine
with the fact that skyscrapers sway back
and forth in the wind skyscrapers
have to worry mostly about when so as
wind is hitting one side of the building
it's going to naturally want to sway a
little bit if wind is able to to rush by
it extremely fast and it's feeling a lot
of positive pressure on this side it
creates what we call a negative Vortex
which can cause it to vibrate pretty
heavily throughout a very tall building
or a skyscraper are installed dampers
which basically counteract the swaying
of the building a certain floor may have
a very large weight such that as the
building begins to sway say this
direction the damper would then move in
the opposite direction to kind of
counteract the amount that is being
swayed but they are hidden from your
typical user of the building they have a
hydraulic actuators that push from one
side to the other usually matching the
frequency that the building is naturally
swinging in the wind at Kate T Kelly
underscore underscore asks concrete
versus cement what's the difference a
cement is actually a powder that creates
a paste when mixed with water and
concrete has not only that cement but
also rocks to make it one big recipe so
cement is actually an ingredient inside
of concrete at St Clement asks these
monstrous elevated freeways Whoever
thought those were a good idea well the
elevation of a freeway has to take into
consideration the vertical space or the
vertical clearance of whatever is
traveling underneath it whenever you
have multiple intersections and several
free ways passing other freeways you
have to make sure that the minimal point
is still high enough for whatever
traffic is traveling underneath it but
you can't just step it up whenever you
need to and so oftentimes the vertical
curve needs to be gradually created over
time the alternative would be to go
under it would be as easy to maintain
and so this calls for certain areas to
look
unnecessarily higher than they need to
be but it's ultimately to try to
accommodate a very smooth experience for
those who are traveling on it those are
all the questions I have time for today
I had a lot of fun thank you so much I
hope you enjoy and learn something
thanks for watching City support